[Music]
good evening to all
david cortès founding president of the
very young obvious structure which which
completes which joins the orientation
which has just been presented previously,
that is to say really focus on
the adoption of desires by  the people
really actually in the
Schumpeterian creation we also have our
own son told me to be concerned about the
people who will undergo these
technological developments and adapt to that so
that all that goes well so
the activity so here I have  the pleasure
also to intervene in the time that
remains in the french tech
corporate community danser initiative
a few years ago which tries to
promote
thanks to you, in particular former
ministers, the interactions between
large groups and a more
more structure  small and in particular the
research laboratories so very concretely
we know what we are proposing to
develop therefore to an airlock tools in a
sovereign environment which allow
to  to approach these issues
to explain explains empowered
black boxes to promote the adoption of
a girl born of this technology in the
company and as much as possible ready to
also prepare the auditability of these
of these
entities so that's it goes through so
we had the pleasure of being corolle co-
winner like when even you express cpr
in July so we actually hope to be
able to
offer to show the value of this
approach there only for sectoral fertilization
between between the different
approaches since a regulatory work
and the
financial aerospace level in the same way
we want to have at the end a real idea of
bustness and the adhesion of every
ne on these subjects here I am so we ar
in ile-de-france and then still
at 4 equivalents  full time it's
still very small so what we
actually expect is to be able to grow
with the
collective on that we mainly
rely on the excesses  we have precisely with the
business experts
to be able to follow these
iterative cycles of explanation and then also we
have already started to do it thanks to thanks
to you in the consequences of
trust and helped from last October 6
with the trellis with
the university  d'artois so we hope to be
able to ship them very soon
here and then also take advantage of
all the open source resources in
particular from dylan it is ova liberati
explains
and it's adventure oil here thank you
very much thank you david
[Music]